[MUSIC PLAYING]
CHRIS CARTLAND: Welcome to
Google+ Developers Live.
My name is Chris Cartland, and
I'm a developer programs
engineer working on the
Google+ platform.
YANIV YAAKUBOVICH: And I'm
Yaniv Yaakubovich.
I'm a product manager on
the Google+ platform.
LEE DENISON: And I'm Lee.
I'm also a developer programs
engineer on the Google+
platform in London.
CHRIS CARTLAND: Yeah, thanks
for joining us via Hangouts
all the way from London.
Today is really exciting.
We're going to talk about
Cross-Platform Single Sign-On,
which is something you may have
seen demonstrated in the
I/O keynote this year.
It's a really cool feature.
We're going to first talk about
what it is, and then
we're going to actually show you
the code and how that fits
into our sample application,
PhotoHunt.
And we will show you all the
details of how to make sure
that you're doing right, and
you can do this in your
application.
So this is really exciting.
First of all, Yaniv, can you
tell us a little more about
what Cross-Platform Single
Sign-On really is?
YANIV YAAKUBOVICH: Sure.
We recognize that users don't
just use one device to
interact with your app.
They switch between laptops,
tablet, and mobile devices on
a daily basis.
And we're focused on making
desktop and mobile work better
together so user will
have a seamless
experience between platforms.
With that, we've taken another
step in this direction, and
we're introducing the
Cross-Platform Single Sign-On,
or as we call it, SSO.
Cross-Platform SSO lets you
connect to users and more
easily keep them engaged across
devices, removing all
the frictions of consent
and authentication.
Now, a user connects on one
device, and seamlessly,
they're connected to
any other device.
Let's look, for example, on the
case of a user that logs
in to your web app to start
adding items to
their shopping cart.
But this user is actually not
completing the transaction,
doesn't check out.
If this user already signed in
with Google+, when using our
Cross-Platform Single Sign-On,
when they go to your web
application, they automatically
sign in to
Google without the need
to consent again or
to authorize anything.
And all of the data is available
for them to use, and
they can check out from exactly
the same place that
they were before in
your website.
CHRIS CARTLAND: That's
really great.
So that would mean that they
could actually buy something
more quickly with less friction
in that app--
YANIV YAAKUBOVICH: Exactly
CHRIS CARTLAND: --make
it easier to do what
they want to do.
That's great.
So yeah, I'd actually love to
see how this actually works.
So if we can--
Lee, I think you can
help us out here.
First, can you explain a
little bit about what
PhotoHunt is?
And then once you've done that,
we can go into actually
the code and how PhotoHunt's
working to do this.
LEE DENISON: Yeah, sure.
So PhotoHunt is a sampler which
demonstrates the Google+
APIs on Android, iOS,
and the web.
It's a game.
It's a photo scavenger hunt
where players capture photos
with their mobile devices
and cameras.
And they submit them
to a daily feed.
And then other players can vote
on their photos to find
out which one is the best one.
But more than our other sampler
applications, it's
really close to a real-world
implementation.
So it is much closer to helping
you understand what
the real world issues you might
face when you try and
implement social login
in your app.
So for example, it implements a
client-server architecture.
So if you've done that in your
own app, then it'll give you
an idea of how to do that.
It has both a signed-out and
a signed-in experience.
So if you're planning to do that
in your app, then you can
see how that works.
And also, it doesn't a more
real-world kind of error
handling flow as well,
particularly on the server
side is a good way to
see how that works.
So it has a server component,
which is implemented in Java.
And we're planning to add more
languages in the future.
And it has client
implementations in JavaScript
for the web and on iOS
and on Android.
These are all available
on GitHub.
And also, the documentation
is available on
developers.google.com/+.
So if we take a look at the
architecture that you get when
you set up a PhotoHunt instance,
then you can see
that we get an Android client
and a JavaScript client.
And each of them authenticate
independently with the Google+
APIs using Google+ sign-in.
And so they can each make direct
calls to the Google
APIs in their own right.
And they can do things like
get the user's profile
information and get their social
graph and all the good
things that you want to do.
They also authenticate with
the PhotoHunt server.
But that is a completely
PhotoHunt-specific API.
So that's nothing to
do with Google.
It's a PhotoHunt-specific API.
But during that process, they
will pass over Google
credentials, which the PhotoHunt
server can then use
to also make calls to
the Google APIs on
behalf of the user.
So if you're writing moments
server side or if you're
getting the social graphs server
side to contribute
there, then you can
also do that.
CHRIS CARTLAND: Yeah, so for
this application, users are
going to authenticate either on
Android or on the web, and
possibly two different places,
they may have to
see a consent dialogue.
And then that information gets
passed to the server, and then
the server does all the
actual API calls to
Google, or most of them.
LEE DENISON: Right.
Exactly.
So for Single Sign-On, what
we're really interested in is
that conversation that goes on
between the clients and Google
rather than the server
and Google.
So let's focus on that.
When a user signs in with a
Google+ Sign-In, then it's
important that Google--
if it's for the very first time
for your service, then
Google needs to show a consent
dialogue, which explains to
the user the permissions that
your app is requesting to be
able to access the Google
APIs and their
data on their behalf.
So that consent dialogue is
displayed natively as part of
Google Play Services on Android
and is displayed as
part of the sign-in
flow on the web.
But with Google+ Sign-In, when
you consent to those
permissions for a given app,
you do that to the project,
regardless of what platform you
happen to be accessing on,
which is great news for
the developers.
So it means Android is
used for the user.
So it means that if I sign in
for the first time on Android
for this app, then I'll
see the native
consent dialogue there.
But then if I subsequently
access the same service via
the web, I won't have
to consent again.
And the same thing happens vice
versa, if you sign in
first on the web.
So that creates a seamless
experience for the user on
Android because the
user has already
authenticated to the device.
So that means that they
don't have to type
in their user name.
They don't have to type
in their password.
And because if they've signed
in already on the web, and
they don't even see the consent
dialogue, that means
that they're dropped straight
to a signed-in experience in
your app without having to
click a single button.
You get the personalized
experience.
And also, as Yaniv said, if they
started anything on the
web, that state will be
available to them immediately
in the app.
YANIV YAAKUBOVICH: And
this goes both ways.
LEE DENISON: Yeah, and
it goes both ways.
So if the user's already signed
in for the first time
on Android, in a browser, if
that's their browser at home,
they're likely to be already
signed in to Google.
And that means that when they
access the service in a web
browser, and the Sign-In button
is displayed, it will
attempt an immediate mobile
authentication.
And because they've already
consented on Android, that
will go ahead.
And again, they'll be signed in
without having to click a
single button.
And they get all the benefits
that way, as well.
CHRIS CARTLAND: That's
really great.
And it's a really neat thing
that we're able to bring this
together on Android and
the web and make
those two more seamless.
LEE DENISON: Yeah.
Now, the great news for
developers is that you don't
need to make any special
changes.
You don't have to do anything
special in your app to
actually implement
Single Sign-On.
It's taken care of for you.
What I'm going to do is take
us through the Android code
for PhotoHunt and explain what's
going on behind the
scenes to make Single
Sign-On happen.
So in Android, as we know, this
Sign-In is handled by the
PlusClient, which
is our interface
to Google Play Services.
And typically, what we do is
we would tie our PlusClient
life cycle to the life cycle
of our activity.
Now, in PhotoHunt, because you
typically want the same
Sign-In logic for every
activity, what you're going to
do is probably either implement
a base activity to
collect that reusable
functionality together, or
what we've done in PhotoHunt
is actually put it in a
reusable fragment.
So let's take a look at
PlusClient fragment.
So like I say, this ties the
PlusClient's life cycle to the
life cycle of the activity.
So we can see that in the
onCreate method of this
PlusClient fragment, we
initialize our PlusClient.
And then we call connect.
We use the PlusClient Builder
to create the PlusClient.
And what we do here is we set
the scopes, which represent
the permissions that your app
is asking of the user.
And we also set the visible
actions, which is the app
activities that your app
would like to write.
Now, it's really important
that the scopes and the
activities that you set are the
same across all platforms.
All the platforms that you
implement need to match,
because if you ask for different
scopes on different
platforms, then when you log
in on the web, say, after
you've already logged in on
Android and you're asking for
different scopes, Google will
have to ask the user for their
consent to them, because you're
asking for a different
set of permissions.
So if you want SSO to work, you
really need to make sure
that those scopes match across
all the platforms that you
implement on.
CHRIS CARTLAND: So like you said
before, you're not really
doing anything new to implement
Single Sign-On.
We're just checking to make sure
that you have things set
up correctly so that right now
on this screen, we can see the
setVisibleActivities
and setScopes.
And those need to be the same
on Android and the web and
across all your platforms.
LEE DENISON: Yeah.
So of course, when you're
implementing on multiple
platforms, you don't get to
define that ahead of somewhere
where you can use
it everywhere.
It's really a developer job.
You've got to make sure that
those are the same across lots
of different platforms.
So yeah.
So at the end of that onCreate
method, we call connect, just
as we would regardless of Single
Sign-On And that does
two things.
It will attempt Sign-On
immediately, and it will
attempt to fetch the sign-in
state of the user.
And to do that, it needs a
connection to Google Play
Services, which is the other
thing you would set up.
And that call is asynchronous
and will ultimately come back
to onConnected if the user has
approved their app anywhere,
on any platform.
And we've got a successful
connection to Google Play
Services, then that'll come
back in onConnected.
And if it fails for some reason,
then it will come back
in onConnectionFailed.
So that's no different
for Single Sign-On.
So PlusClient, of course,
integrates with the Android
Account Manager.
And that means that it already
knows about the Google
accounts on the device and
also whether they are
authenticated in terms
of typing in
user name and password.
So all that we need to do is
decide which account we need
to use and whether or not that
account has approved our app.
Now, that gives us several
possible states
that we can be in.
So you can see here that
if the user has not--
if none of the accounts on the
device have approved our app,
then we're going to get
onConnectionFailed regardless, right?
That might mean if they also
haven't chosen the account,
then we might show them
the Account Chooser.
But whatever else happens, we're
going to have to show
them the consent dialogue.
So that's fine.
That's what users
would expect.
But if they've authorized our
app on any platform, on the
web or Android, then we can see
on the left-hand side that
we've got a number of
options open to us.
So in the common case, in the
case where there's only one
Google account on the device,
then that would be chosen.
It would be the default
account for the app.
And they would get authorized
immediately.
And the next thing that happens
is that onConnected is
called, and our app drops
into its signed-in
state, which is great.
If the user does actually have
more than one Google account
on the device, then it gets a
little bit more complicated.
But it's still handled.
So here, what happens is if
exactly one of those accounts
has authed our app, then again,
we'll get the Single
Sign-On experience.
It will choose that account
as the default account.
And then we'll get you on to
onConnected, which is great.
If more than one of those
accounts has authorized our
app, then we don't know which
one the user needs to pick.
So we have to at least
show them a chooser.
We won't show them a consent
dialogue once they pick, but
we have to show them
the chooser.
So either way, that's
a pretty seamless
experience for the user.
CHRIS CARTLAND: Yeah, and
clearly, there is the case
where you've never authorized.
So you haven't even signed on
once with the app, so you
can't do Single Sign-On
in that case.
LEE DENISON: Exactly.
So if you've never signed in,
and you are, then you're going
to get the onConnectionFailed
regardless.
CHRIS CARTLAND: But once you've
done it once, you end
up in the left column.
And then it's really just a
matter of whether the user has
multiple accounts
on that device.
And Google tries to make a good
decision, but sometimes
you have to let the
user choose.
LEE DENISON: And actually,
the same thing happens
on the web as well.
So if the user is signed into
their browser with multiple
Google accounts, then they'll
get an Account
Chooser there as well.
So the logic is the same
across all platforms.
We handle that case with
multiple accounts, but the
common case is one account,
and there it is.
So the last thing I wanted
to talk about was when
the user signs out.
So here, if you've implemented
sign-in before, you know that
what we do in sign-out is we
clear the default account.
And that forces the Account
Chooser to appear when they
sign in a second time.
Now, Google Play Services
remembers whether or not for
this app we have carried out
the Single Sign-On flow.
So what you'd expect is that
when the user signs out,
they'll see that account user,
regardless of whether the
Single Sign-On flow would've
caused one of them
to be signed in.
And that still works.
So you have to remember
that Google Play
Services remembers that.
And particularly if you're
debugging, it's a good idea
when you want to test Single
Sign-On to go in and clear the
state in Google Play Services.
So that will force the Single
Sign-On flow to happen again
for the app.
So yeah, that really
creates a seamless
experience for the user.
You, as a developer, are doing
exactly what you would have
done before.
You're implementing onConnected
to be your
signed-in experience.
You're implementing
onConnectionFailed to be your
signed-out experience.
And you really do exactly the
same, and Google Play Services
takes care of everything
else for you.
If the user is signed in as a
result of Single Sign-On, they
will get that toast message to
say, welcome back to the app.
And so they're not surprised
by the fact that
they're signed in.
But from your app's perspective,
it just works
exactly the same.
So that's all I have to
say about the Android
implementation.
Cartland, do you want to take
us through the JavaScript
implementation?
CHRIS CARTLAND: Yeah, great.
Yeah, I'm going to briefly look
at the JavaScript for
PhotoHunt as well.
Oh, I guess we forgot to talk
a little bit about the
onConnectionFailed.
That is the same thing that
you would have had before.
And that will help to get the
user through the rare case
where they have multiple apps
that have authorized.
LEE DENISON: Yeah.
CHRIS CARTLAND: Great.
So now, yeah, moving on
to the JavaScript.
The first thing that you need
to make sure you've set up
right is the Sign-In button,
which in PhotoHunt is done
through gapi.signin.render.
We have several fields
that we configure
with the Sign-In button.
And the ones I really want to
call out are the request
visible actions and
the scopes.
We want to make sure that those
are the same as the ones
that Lee talked about in
Android, because, of course,
if you have different scopes,
different permissions, we're
going to have to ask users
for the new permissions.
But once we've set those up,
this is, again, the same
Sign-In button that we had
before Single Sign-On existed.
And the user will click
on that and authorize.
If they authorized either now
on the web or in the Android
flow that Lee just described,
then the callback will be
fired with the authentication
and authorization information
that you need.
So this really has, actually,
no change at this point.
PhotoHunt takes care of knowing
who the user is and
then being the app, which
is really the key here.
We're trying to do all this work
so that as a developer
and as a user, you can just
get to using the app.
You don't want to spend time
signing in and doing all the
other work.
You just want to get to
PhotoHunt where you can
actually deal with stuff.
So that's the stuff there.
YANIV YAAKUBOVICH: If you have
any more questions, we're
welcome to answer them on the
Stack Overflow account.
Just use Google+ as your tag.
You can also see all of those
examples that we discussed
today on developers.google.com/+
or on
our community on Google+
for developers.
CHRIS CARTLAND: Yeah, great.
So thank you so much for
joining us today.
And thank you so much, Lee, for
staying up late in London
to help us out with this.
LEE DENISON: Welcome.
CHRIS CARTLAND: And thank you,
everyone, for watching.
We'll see you next week.
[MUSIC PLAYING]